einen schönen guten tag aus hagen und
herzlich willkommen zu dieser online
vorlesung in der wir uns heute mit der
grounded theory methodologie
beschäftigen wollen
sie werden vermutlich gesehen haben dass
diese vorlesung teil einer trilogie zur
online vorlesung der qualitativen
sozialforschung ist genauer gesagt ist
es der dritte und letzte teil und
deswegen möchte ich ihnen gerne
empfehlen bevor sie weiter schauen dass
sie sich zunächst die erste vorlesung
ansehen
da nämlich werden wir uns mit der
datenerhebung beschäftigen
genauer gesagt mit einer spezifischen
erhebungsmethode der qualitativen
sozialforschung nämlich mit dem
narrativen interview
und außerdem erzähle ich in der ersten
vorlesung etwas über die studie
innerhalb derer die daten erhoben worden
die wir nun im folgenden auswerten
werden und es ist häufig hilfreich dass
man den forschungs kontext einer studie
kennt bevor man sich ihren empirischen
daten zu wertet sie werden diese daten
dann besser einordnen und analysieren
können
gerne können wir uns aber auch noch mal
die ausgangslage vergegenwärtigen
die erste vorlesung nämlich hatte ich
mit den worten beendet des nun der wir
die empirischen daten erhoben haben die
eigentliche arbeit beginnt ja das
übrigens hier eine schöne aufnahme von
gregory bateson und magnit von zwei
ethno krassen die also in dieser szene
hier tatsächlich im feld in einem zelt
sitzen und ihre feld notizen noch schön
mit der schreibmaschine auf arbeiten mit
zelt und schreibmaschine sind wir in der
pilger studie von denen ich ihn schon
erzählt habe nicht konfrontiert worden
aber auch wir waren im feld um die
forschungsfrage zu beantworten ja was
sind eigentlich die auslösenden
biografischen momente die menschen zu
pilgerschaft zu einer pilgerschaft auf
dem jakobsweg veranlassen
um diese frage zu beantworten haben wir
eben negative interviews geführt 30
stück die wurden anhand bestimmter
transaktions regeln transkribiert so
dass uns an diesen punkten und ungefähr
tatsächlich 2000 seiten transkript
vorliegen die wir jetzt auswerten wollen
eben entlang einer grounded theorie
methodologie mit dem ziel eine typologie
zu entwickeln also verschiedene typen
von biografischen auslösern zu
identifizieren und voneinander
abzugrenzen
die menschen zu einer pilgerschaft auf
dem jakobsweg veranlasst haben und ihnen
ist vielleicht aufgefallen dass ich hier
von der grounded theory methodologie
spreche ja es ist also weniger eine
sagen wir mal konkret umrissene methode
der qualitativen sozialforschung die uns
nun genau verfahrensschritte vorgeben
würde was wir nacheinander zu tun haben
um unsere daten auswerten zu können so
wie das zum beispiel bei der
qualitativen inhaltsanalyse der fall ist
nein die dolmetscherin methodologie ist
vielmehr eine haltung gegenüber
empirischen daten sie ist ein verfahren
zu deren systematische auswertung dass
drei ziele haben kann ja so wenn wir
grounded theory methodologie betreiben
dann geht es uns entweder erstens um
eine beschreibung des feldes dass wir
untersuchen wenn sie den studien brief
von goldcorp in gelesen haben zur graue
theorie
dann werden sie dort gesehen haben dass
sie sehr ausführlich erläutert was sie
unter einer grounded description
versteht die durchaus sinn machen kann
dann nämlich wenn wenig
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis zu einem
bestimmten forschungsfeld vorliegt dann
macht es sinn dieses feld zunächst
einmal in systematischer art und weise
zu beschreiben
vormann dann analytische und
interpretativen schritte weitergehen
würde
das zweite ziel eine braune theorie
methodologie kann und da wären wir dann
am eigentlichen sinn der
begrifflichkeiten ja sein ein
theoretisches modell eben eine grounded
theory also eine in empirischen daten
verankerte theorie zu entwerfen und ein
solches theoretisches modell könnte das
wäre dann der dritte mögliche ausgang ja
beispielsweise eine typologie sein so
wie wir sie im folgenden
hier in dieser vorlesung entwerfen
wollen wichtig zu wissen über die graue
theorie methodologie ist dass sie ein
verfahren sehr zentral macht nämlich den
vergleich empirischer daten ja also
immer wieder werden wir bestimmte daten
miteinander vergleichen und zwar im zuge
eines dreistufigen codier prozesses wir
werden also im freundin drei schritte
diskutieren kennenlernen
wichtig zu wissen ist allerdings dass
diese schritte nicht als lineare abfolge
gedacht sind es handelt sich vielmehr
bei der graue theorie methodologie um
einen zirkulären forschungsprozess und
wissen sie das ist jetzt ein gewisser
weise für mich ein didaktisches problem
ja wenn man also ein lehrbuch über graue
theorie schreibt oder eine vorlesung wie
diese hält dann bin ich natürlich
gezwungen ihnen die drei codier schritte
nun in einer bestimmten reihenfolge
vorzustellen
ja das dürfen sie aber nicht
missverstehen in dem sinne dass sie
diese drei schritte einmal durchlaufen
müssten und dann eine braun description
ein theoretisches modell oder eine
typologie entwickelt hätte vielmehr ist
es so dass diese drei schritte sich
immer wieder abwechseln
dass sich die datenerhebung und die
datenauswertung immer wieder abwechseln
das ist das was man innerhalb der graue
theorie methodologie theoretisches
sampling nennt und dieses theoretische
sampling das betreibt man so lange bis
man an einem punkt ist den wir als
theoretische sättigung bezeichnen ja
dieser punkt ist dann erreicht wenn ich
aus neuen daten keine neuen erkenntnisse
mehr gewinnen kann
oder um es in den einschlägigen
begrifflichkeiten zu sagen also wenn es
mir nicht mehr gelingt aus neuen daten
neue konzepte neue kategorien neue
eigenschaften neue dimensionen zu
entwickeln dann habe ich die
theoretische sättigung erreicht
um in das noch deutlicher zu machen habe
ich ein bild mitgebracht das vielleicht
auf den ersten blick auch ein bisschen
chaotisch und verwirrend wirkt das liegt
daran dass es diese quadratur des
kreises auch versucht ja das ist auch
versucht den zirkulären
forschungsprozess in linearer art und
weise darzustellen aber was man doch gut
sehen kann
diesem bild ist dass wir in der grauen
theorie immer zunächst mit der
datenerhebung beginnen ja wir erheben
einen ersten fall und werden ihn aus und
die auswertung ist die basis dafür einen
neuen fall auszuwählen zu erheben
auszuwerten und in diesem prozess werden
uns dann natürlich auch erste
theoretische gedanken kommen ja wir
werden der beantwortung der
forschungsfrage immer ein kleines
stückchen näher kommen und diese
erkenntnisse die sollten wir festhalten
muss sagt man der grounded theory
mythologie und diese schritte der
datenerhebung auswertung und der
theoretisieren die wechseln sich also
immer wieder ab in der vorlesung zur
nation analyse dass die zweite vorlesung
aus unserer triologie habe ich ihnen das
noch ein bisschen deutlicher gemacht es
gibt nämlich die strategien des
minimalen und maximalen vergleichs von
fällen das kann sehr hilfreich sein in
diesem prozess wenn sie mögen können sie
das da also noch mal nachschauen
wenden wir uns aber nun den drei
schritten zu erster schritt wäre immer
ein offenes kodieren ja hier geht es uns
zunächst darum aus den daten heraus
konzepte zu entwickeln sie zu kodieren
da muss sich einschränken dazu sagen
dass diese begrifflichkeiten code und
konzept sehr unterschiedlich und nicht
stringent verwandt werden von
unterschiedlichen protagonisten deck
waren die tiere im mittel theologie für
unsere zwecke ist es glaube ich im
moment ausreichend verbessert synonym
verstehen ja also das konzepte für uns
zunächst mal das gleiche sind auch wenn
bisschen andere theoretische und
methodologische überlegung dahinter
steckt außerdem geht es uns in diesem
ersten schritt ist offenen kodieren
darum bestimmte eigenschaften auch
bestimmte dimensionen zu identifizieren
und schließlich die konzepte die wir
entwickelt haben zu kategorien zu
synthetisieren ja sie damit auch zu
abstrahieren wir schauen uns das gleich
alles anhand eines beispiels an
in einem folgenden schritt ja dem
axialen kodieren würden wir uns dann mit
der frage beschäftigen wie stehen diese
unterschiedlichen kategorien in
zusammenhang
da gibt es ein
eine heuristik die uns dabei hilfreich
sein kann nämlich das sogenannte codier
paradigma und ein dritter schritt
diskutierens wäre dann das sogenannte
selektive kodieren ja hier würde es uns
darum gehen so genannte kernkategorien
herauszuarbeiten
die das von uns untersuchte phänomen
erklären können beziehungsweise die in
der lage sind die von uns entwickelten
typen trend scharf voneinander
abzugrenzen
schauen wir uns diese drei schritte die
sich in zirkuläre art und weise
abwechseln
im folgenden mal ein bisschen genauer an
wenden uns also zunächst dem offenen
codieren zu übrigens sie merken ich habe
ihn auch ein paar bilder mitgebracht die
wir auf dem jakobsweg aufgenommen haben
unter diesem bild sieht man sehr schön
dass man sich auf dem pilgerweg kaum
verlaufen kann weil diese gelben pfeile
wirklich aller orten sind das offene
kodieren also hat das ziel den text das
transkript des negativen interviews
dafür vorliegen haben zunächst mal
aufzubrechen
ja wir wollen alle aussagen die in
diesem text in diesem transkript stehen
mit konzepten versehen die den inhalt
der aussage zusammenfassen er
idealerweise ist das ein sehr kleinen
schritt iges vorgeben also gerade am
anfang würde ich ihn empfehlen
tatsächlich satz für satz zu kodieren
satz für satz konzepte zu entwickeln das
unterscheidet die graue theorie
methodologie damit auch ein bisschen von
der narration analyse ja wenn sie diese
vorlesung gesehen haben dann erinnern
sie sich vielleicht dass ich da gesagt
habe man sollte nicht zu fein
segmentieren
hierbei der graue theorie sollte man
gerade am anfang nicht zu grob
kategorisieren sie werden merken wenn
sie selber mal ja forschend tätig werden
wird sie beispielsweise eine empirische
bachelor oder masterarbeit reime dass
man dann mit der erfahrung
diese strategie auch ein bisschen
verlassen kann und mit der zeit immer
grober kotierter beim anfangen sollten
wir uns wirklich satz für satz vornehmen
das werden wir hier in unserem
forschungs beispiel jetzt auch es so
machen was helfen kann beim offenen
kodieren ist dass wir aktiv fragen an
den text
jaffé fragen also dass wir uns fragen
was ist hier eigentlich los frei
nachgeliefert wird ja also worum geht es
in dem transkript in der aussage die wir
in dem transkript lesen ja wir sind die
handelnden akteure wie interagieren sie
zusammen was sind die begründungen diese
für handel an den tag legen et cetera pp
und das ziel was er mit dem offenen
kodieren erreichen können ist dass wir
am ende einen grundbestand von konzepten
haben eine liste von konzepten und dass
wir uns dann mit der frage beschäftigen
können
wie können wir mehrere konzepte zu einer
kategorie synthetisieren und sie damit
sozusagen auf eine abstraktere
theoretischer ebene hieven
ich würde mir das offene kodieren gerne
mit ihnen anhand eines forschungs
beispiels anschauen das aus unserer
studie stammt ja es ist also ein kleiner
auszug das muss man dazu sagen aus einem
längeren transkript eines negativen
interviews dass wir geführt haben mit
einer deutschen pilgerinnen sie ist gute
40 jahre alt nennen wir sie sabine das
wird im folgenden vielleicht einfacher
sein dass wir einen teutonen vergeben
sabine ist also natürlich nicht richtige
name dieser pilgerin sondern wir müssen
ihre namen anonymisieren das hatte ich
ihnen auch in einer der anderen
vorlesung schon gesagt ja sabine also
pilgert und zwar das ist noch wichtig zu
wissen um dieses transkript verstehen zu
koennen zusammen mit ihrem 16-jährigen
sohn und sabine hat uns unter anderem
freundes berichtet ich bin selbstständig
im beruf das heißt eben sehr strenge
sehr volles arbeitspensum im alltag
ich arbeite im prinzip sieben tage die
woche bin ständig unterwegs ab ständig
termindruck wir also sie und ihr sohn
wir unterhalten uns teilweise in der
kurzform an der tafel steht hängt die
wäsche auf ich bin nicht da und bin um
20 uhr zurück und er schreibt habe ich
gemacht wird beim fußball wir sehen uns
morgen oder so ungefähr
und das kann auf dauer und überhaupt
eine lange zeit nicht sein als wir
begegnen uns im alltag immer nur rein
raus rein raus und haben eigentlich
nicht wirklich zahlen
füreinander natürlich ist erfolg schön
aber es füllt mich irgendwann nicht mehr
aus wenn das nicht mehr den sinn oder
den sinn ergibt den man eigentlich sucht
im leben wenn man sagt man ist ja nur
noch darum zu arbeiten dann muss man
irgendwann mal umdenken wo man sagt was
will ich denn eigentlich
wir sind wir sind ja viel zu materiell
zu organisiert und dieses immer mehr das
ist in deutschland so stark drin
jedenfalls da wo ich mich bewege und das
macht mich krank und es füllt mich nicht
mehr aus und da habe ich gedacht dass
ich für mich man brauche wo ich sage ich
muss mal wirklich eine längere zeit raus
längere zeit nicht darüber nachdenken
was ist das morgen und übermorgen und
dieses was einem alltag so überrollt
sondern einfach wie gesagt ich brauche
meine wirkliche auszeit
das hat so auch noch nicht gegeben dass
ich jetzt 36 tage nicht erreichbar bin
absolut nicht
ich habe das ja nicht dabei das handy
ist aus und wird erst wieder in
deutschland eingeschaltet
also das hat es noch nie gegeben und
viele mussten sich da erst mal daran
gewöhnen dass ich das wirklich ernst
meine im vorfeld dass ich wirklich 36
tage nicht erreichbar bin
von daher bin ich schon sehr beeindruckt
von diesem ganzen ich will nicht sagen
das bringt mich gott und dem glauben
näher oder weiter
es beruhigt eigentlich diese ganze ja
denkweise in mir wo ich sage ich ich
werde von tag zu tag ruhiger ja und das
finde ich so schön so grob sagt sie und
lacht das war so grob meine geschichte
zum pilgern
das ist also das transkript vom
interview mit sabine und nun lassen sie
uns doch dieses transkript zunächst
einmal offen kodieren das heißt wir
gehen es satz für satz durch ja und da
ist ja am anfang dieser satz ich bin
selbstständig im beruf das heißt eben
sehr streng ist sehr volles
arbeitspensum im alltag aus diesem satz
haben wir zwei konzepte gebildet nämlich
einerseits das konzept berufliche
selbstständigkeit und andererseits das
konzept sehr strenges sehr volles
arbeitspensum im alltag das sind zwei
unterschiedliche arten bei dem ersten
handelt es sich um einen sogenannten
soziologisch konstruierten
das heißt wir haben ihn selber
formuliert es sind unsere worte und das
bedeutet dieser code ist ein bisschen
abstrakter ja weil er nicht in den
worten der interviewpartnerin sondern
unseren worten formuliert ist konzept
nummer 2 hingegen ist ein sogenannter in
vivo code das ist also im prinzip ein
zitat das wir sehr unmittelbar aus den
daten entnommen haben
diese in vivo kurz sind schön ich würde
ihnen empfehlen immer dann in vivo codes
zu bilden wenn sie auf einer aussage im
interview stoß und die nun in besonderer
weise bildreich ist die man vielleicht
später in der arbeit im
forschungsbericht in der studie auch gut
zu tieren kann und wenn wir nun weiter
gehen dann haben wir dieses konzept
sabine hat eine sehr hohe
arbeitsbelastung er sie hat kaum
gelegenheit zum austausch mit dem sohn
das kann es auf dauer nicht sein sagt
sie auch hier haben wir also wieder eine
pivot code gebildet und sabine hat keine
zeit für ihr familienleben
lassen sie mich übrigens noch dazu sagen
dass dieses gerade das offene kodieren
ja da gibt es keinen königsweg
ja also die benennung der konzepte liegt
tatsächlich in der hand des forschenden
und es wäre gar nicht schlimm ja wenn
sie sich denken ach dieses konzept würde
ich aber anders nennen
oder wenn sie selber mal versuchen einem
transkript zu kodieren kann es durchaus
sein und es wäre gar kein problem wenn
das sozusagen von meinem vorschlag hier
abweicht wichtig ist eher dass wir uns
später wieder treffen wenn wir in der
theorie methodologie weiter gehen und
dann richtung around the description
oder richtung theoretisches modell gehen
oder richtung typen bild umgehen dann
sollten wir doch ähnliche
forschungsergebnisse produzieren aber in
diesem ersten schritt des offenen
kodieren es liegt die formulierung der
konzepte wirklich in ihrer hand und dann
geht es weiter
ja dann ist da dieser satz natürlich ist
erfolg schön aber es fällt mich
irgendwann nicht mehr aus auch ihre zwei
konzepte gebildet einerseits nämlich
dass sabine erfolgsorientiert ist
andererseits dass dieser erfolg ihr
keine erfüllt
ergibt das passiert häufig dass in einem
satz zwei verschiedene aussagen städten
die mit zwei kunden verschiedenen
konzepten codiert werden sollten weil in
unter umständen auch weil zwischen
beiden konzepten vom interviewpartner
ein kausaler zusammenhang aufgemacht
wird ein zweiter sabine hat ein sehr
strenges arbeitspensum das ergibt keinen
sinn es wäre unserem konzept nummer 9
sie befindet sich auf sinnsuche und sagt
diesem durchaus zitierfähigen platz den
man kurz und wiedergutmachen kann ja man
ist ja eigentlich nur noch darum zu
arbeiten
dann muss man irgendwann umdenken sagt
sie wo man sich fragt was will man denn
eigentlich es ist zeit zum umdenken
haben wir das konzept genannt und was
will man denn eigentlich ist ein weitere
in vivo code dann sagt sabine diesen
eher reflektierenden satz der
argumentativen charakter hat über diese
materielle orientierung in deutschland
über die organisiertheit der dinge da
haben wir gesagt nicht nur das
materielle orientierung und organisiert
hat geht sondern dass der biene diese
explizit ablehnt ich denke es wird sehr
deutlich in diesem satz herrn und dass
sie keine erfüllung mehr im beruf findet
sie möchte deshalb mit raus aus dem
alltag ich brauche einen cut und nimmt
deshalb eine längere auszeit in der sie
nicht mehr über den alltag nachdenken
möchte dass das konzept nummer 18
sie nimmt den jakobsweg also als eine
auszeit konzept 29 erstmals ist sie für
längere zeit nicht erreichbar ist auch
eine spannende passage in diesem
transkripte weil verdienen so deutlich
betont ich bin jetzt 36 tage lang nicht
erreichbar
zum ersten mal wenn meine freunde meine
bekannten meine arbeitskollegen zu hause
die mussten sich da erst mal irgendwann
finden das kristallisiert sich im fall
von sabine auch das ist interessant ja
offenbach es anhand eines technischen
defekts
anhand ihres handys von dem aber da
werden wir jetzt schon interpretativen
sehr weit also vermuten können dass das
handy in sabines alltagsleben offenbar
eine hohe bedeutung hat
wahrscheinlich ist das handy immer
präsent und sie widmet ihm sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit und das ist nun hier auf
dem jakobsweg geben offenbar völlig
anders nämlich das handy bleibt aus und
es wird auch in deutschland erst wieder
eingeschaltet
da musste sich das soziale umfeld wie
gesagt daran gewöhnen und schließlich
das ist dann schon fast die coda dieser
passage des transkripts die wir uns hier
anschauen
er fasst sie zusammen dass sie
beeindruckt von diesem ganzen ist und
sie meint damit den jakobsweg sagt auch
dass er für sie offenbar nur unmittelbar
religiöse bedeutung hat also dass sie
nicht das gefühl hat dass sie gott näher
kommt auf dem jakobsweg ja aber der
jakobsweg beruhigt ihre denkweise und
schließlich ein letzter in vivo code den
wir aus dem letzten satz dieses auszugs
gebildet haben
ich werde von tag zu tag hier auf dem
jakobsweg ruhiger hand das also unser
vorschlag wie man dieses transkript von
sabine offen kodieren könnte und das ist
zwischenergebnis dass wir nun haben ist
eine liste von konzepten für die praxis
würde ich ihn empfehlen dass sie beim
offenen kodieren genauso vorgehen ja
also dass sie letztendlich eine liste
entwickeln
in der sie alle konzepte auflisten sie
sollten diese konzepte das wird dann
nachher einfacher durchnummerieren so
wie es hier getan haben und ganz wichtig
ist dass sie zu jedem konzept die
fundstelle festhalten dass sie sagen
also aus welchem abschnitt aus welcher
aussage aus welchem satz des transkripte
transkript das hab ich dieses konzept
eigentlich entwickelt das ist wichtig
weil es ein güte kriterium der
qualitativen sozialforschung erfüllt
nämlich die transparenz und die inter
subjektive nachvollziehbar kann das
heißt wenn sie mit solchen listen und
tabellen arbeiten dann werden sie
jederzeit an jedem punkt des
forschungsprozess
das nachvollziehen können welche
schlüsse sie aus welchen daten gezogen
haben und ein weiterer tipp aus der
forschungspraxis wäre wenn sie diese
tabelle erstellt haben dass sie nun
zunächst mal nach redundanzen schauen ja
also dass sie schauen welche konzepte
entsprechen einander
das ist nicht unwichtig um die daten
handhabbar zu halten also sie müssen
sich ja noch mal vorstellen
wir haben jetzt in dieser studie
tatsächlich 2000 seiten transkript ja
und ich weiß nicht wie viele konzepte
entwickelt haben und es macht sinn also
zu schauen dass diese daten handhabbar
bleiben und dass man redundanzen bereits
früh reduziert ist eigentlich ein
vorgehen das man eher in der
qualitativen inhaltsanalyse findet dass
man aber mit vorsicht auch in der grande
theorien methodologie anwenden kann und
so fallen mir in dieser liste
zwei konzepte auf die ähnlichkeit haben
das einmal das konzept nummer vier
also kaum gelegenheit zum austausch mit
dem sohn und das konzept nummer 6 keine
zeit für familien leben
die wirken auf mich zumindest für unsere
forschungs frage sehr ähnlich und
deshalb würde ich vorschlagen dass wir
sie zusammenfassen zu einem gemeinsamen
konzept nummer fünf keine zeit für
familien leben wichtig ist dass sie dann
in ihre liste beide fundstellen
markieren wenn sie direkt und ganz von
konzepten reduzieren
nochmal ich hatte gesagt diesen schritt
muss man mit einer gewissen vorsicht
gehen wenn man noch mal kurz
zurückschauen ist es natürlich auch so
dass wir durch dieses zusammenführen von
konzepten gewisse informationen
verlieren
ja denn dem konzept nummer vier im
ursprünglichen konzept nummer vier
spricht sie explizit davon dass sie
keine gelegenheit zum austausch mit dem
sohn hat eben mit dem so also nicht mit
einer tochter oder mit dem ehemann oder
mit freunden
ja also diese detailinformationen
verschenken wir wenn wir insgesamt sagen
sie hat keine zeit mehr für den
austausch innerhalb der familie für das
familienleben
das halte ich aber tatsächlich für
unsere fragestellung hier für
vernachlässigbar und für eine
information auf die wir gut an dieser
stelle verzichten können
der nächste schritt der auch noch zu
dieser ersten stufe des offenen kodieren
gehört wäre nun diese konzepte her zu
nehmen und sie zu kategorien zusammen zu
führen die dann schon auf einem deutlich
abstrakteren niveau liegen
ich will ihn mal zwei beispiele zeigen
wie wird es gemacht haben
das sind zum einen diese vier konzepte
strenges arbeitspensum ergibt keinen
sinn mehr sinn suchen
was will man denn eigentlich erfolg gibt
keine erfüllung mehr
diese vier konzepte haben wir zur
kategorie sinnkrise zusammengefasst ja
da steckt jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
hin also vielleicht stolpern sie ein
bisschen und sagen das ist schon starker
begriff zu sagen es handelt sich
wirklich um eine sinnkrise man könnte
auch etwas vorsichtiger beispielsweise
die kategorie erstmal sinnsuche nennen
ja dann hat sie nicht so einen
normativen charakter
gleichwohl glaube ich dass im fall von
sabine der begriff sinnkrise ganz gut
das trifft was eigentlich in ihrem leben
gerade zentral ist und in der forschungs
realität muss ich auch dazu sagen waren
es noch viel mehr konzepte die wir zu
dieser kategorie zugeordnet haben weil
das transkript ja insgesamt viel länger
ist als diesen aus mit denen wir uns
angeschaut haben aber auch hier noch mal
es gibt keinen königsweg bereits unser
vorschlag zu sagen wir nennen die erste
kategorie sinnkrise ein weiteres
beispiel ist das folgende jahr diese
drei konzepte also sabine hat ja gesagt
kann man sehr streng sehr voll
arbeitspensum am alltag sie hat also
eine hohe arbeitsbelastung und dann gibt
es diesen in die druck und man ist ja
nur noch da um zu arbeiten und diese
drei haben wir zusammengefasst zur
kategorie stress im beruf und so sind
wir nun alle konzepte durchgegangen und
das bedeutet unser nächstes ergebnis
dass dann auch schon das endgültige
ergebnis des offenen kodieren es ist ist
eine liste erneut eine tabelle aber
diesmal eben von kategorien
um das schnell zu unterscheiden können
wäre meine empfehlung dass sie
kategorien mit römischen ziffern
durchnummerieren
während wir eben die konzepte ja mit den
arabischen ziffern 0 agiert hatten so
fällt es leichter sie auf den ersten
blick zu unterscheiden und auch hier
noch mal wichtig die die transparenz die
inter subjektive nachvollziehbarkeit ja
in dieser liste von kategorien müssen
wir nun also festhalten welche konzepte
haben wir zu dieser kategorie jeweils
zusammengefasst so dass erneut der weg
nachvollziehbar bleibt vom ergebnis bis
zu den daten
wir sehen nämlich hier die kategorie
eins hat folgende konzepte und können
dann in unserem konzept tabelle
nachschauen
aus welchem fundstellen haben wir die
konzepte entwickelt der fähig von der
kategorie zu den eigentlichen daten es
also jederzeit nachvollziehbar
sie sehen auch kategorien können ganz
unterschiedlich viele konzepte
beinhalten das ist kein problem er also
die diese erste kategorie sinnkrise
umfasst jetzt in unserem fall sechs
konzepte jahr während die kategorien
vier und fünf jeweils nur aus einem
konzept bestehen und das wäre zunächst
mal der erste schritt des kopierens das
offen codieren und in einem nächsten
schritt würden wir jetzt zum axialen
kodieren wechseln
ich hatte bereits gesagt dass es uns nun
um verbindungs geflechte zwischen den
kategorien geht der wenn an dieser
stelle durchaus ein bisschen spielen mit
den kategorien ja dass das kann man sehr
gut
beispielsweise machen indem man die
kategorien sich auf karteikärtchen
schreibt und sie alle auf den tisch legt
und sie dann versucht zu sortieren und
zu schauen wie stehen diese kategorien
in einem zusammenhang
da gibt es eine heuristik die sehr
prominentes in der theorie methodologie
nämlich dass q dir paradigma gucken wir
uns auch das an
wichtig zu wissen axial diskutieren
heißt axia diskutieren weil es eine
achse in den mittelpunkt
und auf dieser achse liegt ein phänomen
ja also das phänomen was zentral ist für
das transkript für den auszug aus einem
transkript denen wir hier analysieren
wollen und diese achse wird begrenzt
einerseits von ursächlichen bedingungen
des phänomens la und andererseits von
konsequenzen und der link zwischen
ursächlichen bedingungen und
konsequenzen das sind bestimmte
handlungsstrategien es gibt ursachen
dafür dass ein akteur in bestimmter
weise handelt und daraus entstehen
konsequenzen und das phänomen wird
flankiert von bestimmten kontext
bedingungen ja von man könnte auch sagen
intervenierenden bedingungen also von
zeitlichen örtlichen bedingungen vom
sozialen und kulturellen umfeld in dem
das phänomen angesiedelt ist aber auch
von der individuellen biografie des
handelnden akteurs beispielsweise und
wenn wir jetzt unsere kategorien die wir
aus dem konstrukt von verdienen
entwickelt haben mal versuchen in dieses
schema einzusortieren eben gerne mit
karteikärtchen die auf einem tisch
liegen dann wäre mein vorschlag dass wir
ins zentrum unseres kunden parat x-mal
paradigmas die kategorie jakobsweg als
auszeit stellen
denn ich glaube das ist worum es bei
sabine geht ja sie nimmt den jakobsweg
her um aus ihren stressigen beruflichen
alltag heraus zu kommen zunächst die
kontext bedingungen ja da würden wir die
beiden kategorien einordnen dass sabine
selbstständig ist dass sabine
erfolgsorientiert ist also persönliche
eigenschaften fehlen wir hierzu den
kontext bedingungen auf der seite der
ursachen würde ich drei kategorien
anordnen nämlich stress im beruf die
kategorie sinnkrise und die kategorie
keine zeit für familie und die
handlungsstrategie die sabine an den tag
legt die es glaube ich recht
offensichtlich ja sie ist für lange zeit
nicht erreichbar
dieses
36 tage die das handy aus und diese
handlungsstrategie hat eine konsequenz
nämlich serbien findet auf dem jakobsweg
ruhe und sie ist beeindruckt vom
jakobsweg
das wäre also mein vorschlag wie man die
kategorien wie ich finde plausibler
weise miteinander in beziehung bringen
könnte anhand eines codier paradigmas
auch hier gibt es aber noch keinen
königsweg also in der praxis ist es eher
so wenn sie mit den kategorien ein
bisschen spielen auf dem tisch und sie
versuchen in eine beziehung zu bringen
dass sie mehrere codier paradigma
entwickeln ja aber es wird ihnen dann
auch auffallen dass es sehr häufig eben
ein kurier paradigma gibt dass die
kategorien in besonders plausibler und
schlüssiger art und weise miteinander in
beziehung setzt und dann müssen wir ein
stück weiter gehen
damit verlassen wir das sollte ich
vielleicht dazu sagen im übrigen auch
die übungsaufgabe die sie in mode finden
wenn sie das modul 1 2 des
bachelorstudiengangs politikwissenschaft
verwaltungswissenschaft soziologie
studieren denn da stellen wir ihnen im
rudel jahr ein
ein reales transkript aus der pilger
studie zur verfügung und laden sie ein
also das wirklich mal offen zu kodieren
indem sie konzepte bilden redundanz
reduzieren sie zur kategorien
synthetisieren und dann im rahmen des
axialen kodieren versuchen diese
kategorien miteinander in beziehung zu
bringen
ich denke so weit kommt man wenn man nur
den auszug eines einzelnen vereins hat
und in bezug auf diese übungsaufgabe in
mode ist also sozusagen diese vorlesung
an dieser stelle beendet aber ich möchte
ihm anbieten wenn sie lust haben dass
wir jetzt noch ein stück weiter schauen
ja dann damit sie auch sehen also was
ist denn aus dieser studie tatsächlich
geworden wir haben wir weitergemacht mit
der graue theorie methodologie und
welche forschungsergebnisse welche
typologie haben wir am ende entwickelt
und
um so weit zu kommen müssen wir
natürlich jetzt den einzelnen fall
verlassen ja also wir haben hier erstens
mit sabine zu tun wo es um den jakobsweg
als auszeit geht und mit der
handlungsstrategie lange zeit nicht
erreichbar zu sein aber es gab natürlich
noch andere fälle ich habe gesagt es
wurden insgesamt 30 negative interviews
geführt beispielsweise mit einem schüler
der den jakobsweg nach seinem abitur
gegangen hätte und er hat unter anderem
in seinem interview gesagt es wäre ein
ebook
sie werden stolz auf mich sein herr
meine familie insbesondere zu hause aber
auch meine freunde
sie werden stolz auf mich sein dass ich
in so jungen jahren alleine auf den
jakobsweg gegangen bin und diese er
tatsächlich 800 kilometer von soccer und
ihre pforten bis santiago de compostela
zu fuß gegangen bin
trotz aller anstrengung und wir haben
auch ein interview geführt mit einem 80
jährigen deutschen der den jakobsweg
sozusagen am ende seines lebens gibt
jetzt nicht unsere interpretation dass
er kurz vor dem ende seines lebens steht
nein das ist auch etwas das aus den
daten stand ja ganz explizit sagte der
rentner nämlich das hier ist meine
letzte große reise also er hat das ende
seines lebens auf dem jakobsweg ständig
präsent und vor augen und der renner
sagt unter anderem ich werde denen alles
zeigen und berichten damit meint er zu
hause seine familie ja deswegen macht er
auch unheimlich viele fotos und er
schreibt jeden tag sehr ausführlich
tagebuch und er hat die ganze zeit diese
vorstellung die armen enkel dass sobald
er nach hause kommt ja eher eine einen
diavortrag macht und alles was er erlebt
hat genau berichtet und wenn wir uns
diese drei fälle jetzt mal in der
zusammenschau angucken und gucken wo es
eigentlich die gemeinsamkeit dann geht
es in allen drei fällen oder in diesen
drei aussagen die ich
jetzt hier zeige um das verhältnis des
pilgernden zum heimischen sozialen
umfeld sabine ist lang nicht erreichbar
der schüler er denkt sein heimisches
soziales umfeld explizit mit ja
eigentlich geht er auch für das
heimische soziale umfeld pilgern weil er
die anerkennung haben möchte weil er die
erfahrung machen möchte dass seine
familie stolz auf ihn ist ja und der
ränder sowieso denn er hält vieles fest
und möchte den zu hause alles zeigen
die gemeinsamkeit dieser drei kategorien
aus drei unterschiedlichen fällen ist
also dass es jedes mal um das heimische
soziale umfeld geht und in den worten
der grauen theorie methodologie haben
wir damit eine erste kernkategorien
identifiziert mit der wir nun mittendrin
sind im selektiven codieren lassen uns
damit noch ein bisschen weitermachen mit
drei anderen aussagen sabine sucht
nämlich auf dem jakobsweg explizite
gemeinschaft es ist für sie eine ganz
neue erfahrung dass sie hier auf andere
menschen trifft die sie einfach erst mal
nehmen wie sie ist und die keine
erwartungen an sich stellen und sie
sucht dieses für sie schöne gefühl der
geborgenheit in der gemeinschaft mit
anderen pilgern auch der schüler legt
sehr viel wert auf seine begegnung auf
dem jakobsweg allerdings aus einem etwas
anderen grund der schüler sucht nämlich
anregungen für sein künftiges leben also
er beschäftigt sich explizit mit der
frage was möchte ich im leben eigentlich
jetzt nach meiner schulzeit machen ja
und ist sehr sensibel dafür hinweise die
im andere pilger geben also wenngleich
auch aus dem interview mit ihm noch eine
passage lesen in der er von einer
lehrerin erzählt eine für ihn ganz
besondere begegnung das wären wir gleich
sehen zunächst der rentner noch der
sucht nämlich nun gar keinen kontakt auf
dem jakobsweg er geht den weg im
regelfall allein
stille ist ihm wichtig und er sagt nun
gut abends in der herberge sprechen mich
natürlich andere pilger an und dann muss
sich small talk mit ihnen halten aber
eigentlich möchte ich auf dem jakobsweg
kleine sein und auch hier geht es also
bei allen drei kategorien um um ein und
dasselbe nämlich die frage wie
kommunizieren die pilger auf dem
jakobsweg
und noch eine dritte sagen wir mal kern
kategorie kabinen hat wie alle pilger
ein spezifisches verhältnis zur
körperlichkeit ja die spielt auf dem
jakobsweg natürlich eine große rolle ich
sagte gerade schon markierte 800
kilometer zu fuß und das geht natürlich
nicht ohne schmerzen ohne gelenkprobleme
ohne muskelkater und ohne diese diese
alle gegenseitigen fuß blasen ja die man
sehr regelmäßig zählt und rituell
versorgt und über die man vier spricht
und sagt diese fußball hatten hast du
denn eigentlich gestern gelaufen und so
herr und auch für sabine spielt diese
körperliche anstrengungen und große
rolle
sie gibt ihr nämlich neuen rhythmus
während sie zu hause dieses stressigen
berufsleben hat ist es nun so dass diese
körperliche anstrengung die auch so eine
gewisse monotonie hat ja ich gehe den
ganzen tag schritt für schritt die
beruhigt sie letztendlich und gibt ihr
einen festen rhythmus für den schüler
spielt körperlichkeit eine große rolle
er erlebt sie nämlich als reifeprüfung
ja er möchte sich aber eben explizit auf
seinem heimischen sozialen umfeld
beweisen dass er das kann und auch für
den rentner haben schmerzen eine sehr
besondere bedeutung die ich sehr
interessant finde er erlebt sie nämlich
als buße für die negativen dinge seines
lebens nämlich so dass er jeden tag ja
jeden tag den er auf dem jakobsweg
unterwegs ist explizit einen bestimmten
abschnitt seiner biografie einen
bestimmten lebensabschnitt im kopf
präsent hat dass er sich jeden tag mit
einer phase seines lebens
auseinandersetzt ja und dass er dabei
auch an dinge denkt die vielleicht nicht
so gut gelaufen sind
die er falsch gemacht hat mit denen
anderen menschen weh getan hat und er
sagt dass er wenn es mir dann selber ja
an diesem tag weh tut wenn mir die füße
wehtun wenn das pilgern an diesem tag
besonders anstrengend ist dann ist es
eine buße für das was ich im leben
falsch gemacht habe
in allen drei fällen geht es also um die
bedeutung und auch die individuelle
deutung von körperlichkeit und
körperlicher anstrengung und jetzt sind
wir einem spannenden punkt der pilger
studie
wenn man sich also in dieser art und
weise wie wir es jetzt getan haben mit
empirischen daten beschäftigt dann gibt
es oder hoffentlich zumindest dann gibt
es irgendwann einen punkt den man den
produktiven geistesblitz nennt also
plötzlich ist es so dass man in diesen
ganzen daten die man zunächst unsortiert
vor sich liegen hatte muster erkennt
dass man bestimmte zusammenhänge erkennt
und im fall der pilger studie war es
eben so dass christian kurat irgendwann
erkannt hat tatsächlich ist es so dass
der biografische auslöser für eine
pilgerschaft in typischer weise bestimmt
wie der bilder dieses typs mit seinem
heimischen sozialen umfeld umgeht wie
auf dem jakobsweg kommuniziert und
welche bedeutung er diesen aspekt der
körperlichkeit beim ist ja und das ist
ein toller moment in dem man plötzlich
zusammenhänge in den daten erkennt ja
und in dem man in dem einem plötzlich
dinge klar werden und man seine
forschungsergebnisse ein ganzes stück
näher gekommen ist und deswegen möchte
ich sie auch gerne noch mal dazu anregen
wenn sie die chance mal haben selber
empirisch zu forschen
ja indem sie eine empirische
abschlussarbeit schreiben beispielsweise
nutzen sie die chance weil es ist ein
ganz tolles erlebnis dann an diesem
punkt des abdruckt even geistesblitze
bekommen und damit sind wir dann auch
fast schon bei unserem
forschungsergebnis nennen denn wir haben
mit diesen drei kernkategorien man
könnte auch sagen mit diesen drei
typisierungs dimensionen nun die
möglichkeit verschiedene typen von
biografischen auslösern voneinander
abzugrenzen und sind dabei sozusagen
beim finalen schritt ja unserer daten
auswertung und interpretation bei der
typen bildung
insgesamt konnten wir aus den 30
artikeln interviews die uns vorliegen
aus unseren daten fünf typen entwickeln
den ersten typ haben wir genannt
biografische auszeit und für den steht
eben die sabine ja das transkript dass
wir gerade gelesen haben also wir reden
hier von menschen die im alltag ja
extremen anforderungen und stress
besonders beruflicher natur ausgesetzt
sind und die dadurch in eine sinnkrise
geraten und die das pilgern als
entschleunigung nehmen und die nachruhe
und sinn suchen auf dem jakobsweg und
wir hatten eben gerade schon gesagt ja
das sind menschen dem diese gemeinschaft
erfahrung wichtig ist auf dem jakobsweg
die durch die körperliche anstrengung
rhythmus und gelassenheit wiederfinden
und die aber keinen kontakt zum
heimischen sozialen umfeld haben sondern
die ganz explizit sagen nein ich mache
eine auszeit und mit denen zu hause
möchte ich jetzt zb für 36 tage keinen
kontakt haben
das transkript von sabine hatten wir
eben schon gelesen
ein zweiter typ wäre der typus
biografischer übergang das ist der für
den schüler produkte besteht ja also
menschen die sagen wir am ende einer in
der normal biografie vorgesehenen
lebensphase sind ja und die versuchen
den übergang von einer lebensphase in
die andere lebensphase zu gestalten auch
durchaus auf dem jakobsweg rituell zu
gestalten
es muss nicht immer am ende der
schullaufbahn sein
so zählen beispielsweise auch
absolventen die gerade ihr studium
abgeschlossen haben oder hierzu zählen
menschen die gerade in rente gegangen
sind diese menschen das hat mir eben
schon von dem schüler gesagt suchen also
explizit auch den austausch mit anderen
pilgern
einer sei es um die vergangenheit also
die abgeschlossenen lebensphase zu
besprechen
andererseits um anregungen zu suchen für
die zukunft für die neue lebensphase die
körperlichkeit steht hier im
zusammenhang mit einer reifeprüfung und
was was den kontakt zum heimischen
sozialen umfeld angeht müssen wir ein
bisschen differenzieren
ja die jungen pilger dieses typus die
versuchen sich nämlich durch die
pilgerschaft von anderen abzugrenzen
das ist zum beispiel auch bei dem
schüler ganz deutlich hier berichtet
nämlich davon ja jetzt nach unserem
abitur haben wir alle etwas besonderes
gemacht aber meine ganzen anderen
freunde
die sind in urlaub gefahren die sind
zusammen nach mallorca gefahren ja und
er sagt relativ wörtlich die liegen da
nur am strand und haben am ende ein
sonnenbrand und dem dicken kopf und
weiter nichts davon und ich bin aber
hier auf dem jakobsweg und ich setze
mich explizit mit meiner zukunft
auseinander und die l den älteren
menschen dieses typus ist eher daran
gelegen mit dem jakobsweg und seine
bewältigung körperliche
leistungsfähigkeit zu demonstrieren also
wenn man so will geht es den jungen
darum zum ausdruck zu bringen
ich kann es schon und den älteren geht
es darum zum ausdruck zu bringen ich
kann es noch
lassen sie uns lassen sie uns von dem
schüler auch mal eine eine interview
passage lesen die diese punkte noch mal
sehr deutlich macht er sagt nämlich und
dann ist hape kerkeling diesen weg hier
gepilgert
dann habe ich das buch gelesen und durch
ihn wurde dass wir in deutschland auch
ziemlich populär
ja dann habe ich mich halt immer mehr
dafür interessiert mich gefragt ob ich
das machen kann ob ich es körperlich
schaffe
ob ich ja das ist ja auch eine geistige
herausforderung sich mit sich selbst
auseinanderzusetzen
also ich war mir noch nicht so klar was
ich nach der schule machen soll
ich hatte überlegt zur bundeswehr zu
gehen und dazu studieren und mich für
längere zeit also 13 bis 16 jahre zu
verpflichten und als soldat auf zeit zu
arbeiten und hatte aber noch zwei drei
andere optionen wie zum beispiel lehrer
oder förster hatte ich auch lange zeit
im hinterkopf noch also sehr
verschiedene richtungen auch und jahren
aber ich glaube dass sich auf dem weg
hier zumindest schon den soldaten
ausschließen konnte für mich und so wie
ich mir das momentan überlegt habe war
die tendenz dazu dass ich das was ich
hier für mich gelernt habe auch anderen
weitergeben will
und ich glaube deswegen ist lehrer doch
die 90 prozent tendenz ja das ist
eigentlich das was ich wissen wollte
ich bin jetzt mit der schule fertig das
ist ja doch ein recht großes kapitel im
leben was macht man nach dem abitur
macht man jetzt die sechs monate
grundwehrdienst so sachen wollte ich mir
hier überlegen und bisher hat es
eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert und
hatte eben schon angedeutet also
besonders diese idee dass der schüler
lehrer werden möchte steht in starkem
zusammenhang mit einer schon älteren
lehrerin einer amerikanerin bier auf dem
jakobsweg trifft und die ihn auch
einlädt zu sich in die usa zu kommen und
für einige zeit an ihrer schule zu
hospitieren ja das ist für für unsere
schüler unsere abiturienten hat diese
begegnung große bedeutung der
transzendiert sie interessanterweise
auch und sagt im interview solche sätze
wie diese frau hat mir gott geschenkt ja
und sie hat mich auf den richtigen weg
für meine zukunft gebracht
ein dritter typ wäre der typus
biografische bilanzierung ja das ist im
prinzip unser rentner über den wir eben
schon gesprochen haben also menschen die
für sich das ende ihres lebens in sicht
haben und sich damit auseinandersetzen
die rückschau halten wollen auf ihr
bisheriges leben und die einordnen und
bewerten möchten was in ihrem leben
passiert ist
die suchen keinen kontakt mit anderen
suchen
stille und einkehr
nur wenige gespräche mit anderen pilgern
die erleben die schmerzen als buße für
negative lebenserfahrung und für sie hat
das heimische soziale umfeld erleben
eine eine hohe bedeutung erinnern sie
sich an den rentner sagt ich möchte den
alles zeigen die bilder des typs
biografische bilanzierung wollen also
wenn man so will ein vermächtnis
schaffen für die zukunft auch hier
können wir gerne ein bisschen in die
datenreihen fahren auch hier ein kurzer
auszug aus einem transkript mit eben
jenem 80 jährigen deutschen
er sagt ich muss sagen dass ich das
ganze als ein dankeschön ansehe
dankeschön nach oben
ich hatte eine sehr harte berufszeit ich
bin 80 jahre habe früh schon seit dem
berufsleben ein sehr hartes berufsleben
der hauptschule berufsleben aber auch
sehr mit großen herausforderungen und
großen forderungen an mich und auch an
die familie und er gibt es da gab es ja
auch menschen oder leute die ein
gefördert haben und dann die ich gerne
denke die vielleicht doch nicht mehr
leben oder nicht mehr da sind
aber man erinnert sich an diese menschen
die es mit einem gut gemeint haben die
an gefördert haben
und dahin gehen meine gedanken und die
gespräche und ein dankeschön an die die
einem im leben begegnet sind und
unterstützt haben aufgemuntert haben und
auch freunde freude bereitet haben
das ist für mich ganz wichtig denn nicht
alles was man selbst erreicht hat ist
nur auf eigene körperkraft oder
intelligenz entstanden sondern es haben
auch andere mitgeholfen das darf man
nicht vergessen und diese dinge gehen
natürlich auch zurück bis ins elternhaus
wo man sich auch seinen eltern oder
großeltern gegenüber gerne erinnert oder
an geschwister die nicht mehr leben und
so weiter die man immer wieder dann auch
in die gedanken mit einbezieht
ich möchte an mein leben das ich bisher
gelebt habe und die stationen gerne
zurückdenken und dafür brauche ich
stelle wenn ich am anfang gesagt habe es
war ein wunsch von mir muss ich
mittlerweile sagen es ist fast schon so
es ist kein wunsch sondern es dann ruf
gewesen
zu tun und es bestätigt mich auch mit
jedem schritt mit allem was ich hier
sehe und schließlich gibt es noch zwei
weitere typen von biografischen
auslösern für eine pilgerschaft nämlich
zum einen die biografische krise das
sind also menschen deren leben durch ein
ungeplantes ereignis in der nahen
vergangenheit erschüttert wurde und die
pilgern um dieses ereignis zu
verarbeiten und wieder zur ruhe zu
kommen
diese menschen haben auch expliziten
kontakt mit anderen pilgern sie finden
nämlich trost in den anderen und werden
sich auch ihres eigenen glückes wusste
aus einem interview stand zum beispiel
der satz dass jemand erkannt hat dass
auch andere ihr päckchen zu tragen haben
also dass man nicht alleine ist mit
einer schmerzhaften krisenerfahrung was
die körperlichkeit angeht spielt sich
auch eine große bedeutung für pilger
dieses typs jahr körperlichkeit und
schmerzen erleben sie nämlich als
reinigung die dazu führt dass wieder ein
gleichgewicht entsteht zwischen körper
geist und seele und das heimische umfeld
ist interessanterweise für diese
menschen völlig unbedeutendes also auch
anders bei sabine beim typ biografische
auszeit ja die hat sich zwar auch völlig
völlig den kontakt unterbrochen zu ihrem
heimischen sozialen umfeld aber durch
dieses aktive nicht erreichbar seien ja
als handlungsstrategie hat das heimische
soziale umfeld natürlich noch alle
gespielt explizit hat sie den kontakt
unterbrochen
beim typus biografische krise ist es nun
so dass die entsprechenden pilger gar
nicht ja gar nicht an ihr heimisches
soziales umfeld denkt ist für sie
einfach während der pilgerschaft
unbedeutend weil sie auf während ihre
pilgerschaft das eigene heim suchen
auch hier möchte ich ihnen ein beispiel
geben
wir haben es in der ersten vorlesung
unserer triologie
kurz gehört es geht um eine junge frau
die uns vom tod ihres vaters berichtet
und sie sagt und dann ist mein papa
gestorben und das hat mich sehr
mitgenommen weil ich sehr an meinem
vater hin und dann war das irgendwie für
mich klar
um mit diesem schmerz besser umgehen zu
können ich muss irgendwie aktiv werden
ich muss was machen und dann war
plötzlich klar jakobsweg das war's dann
einfach und das fand ich für mich
wichtig weil durch die bewegung hast du
die möglichkeit etwas zu verarbeiten was
schmerzt und ich glaube es ist viel
besser so etwas in bewegung zu
verarbeiten zum stillen kämmerchen für
mich war es wichtig das auch zu tun
etwas zu tun dass der schmerz besser
verarbeitet werden kann dass das alles
raus kommen kann und auch die
begegnungen auf dem weg ja vor allem
wenn das begegnung mit einzelnen
menschen waren die waren sehr intensiv
weil ich habe mein herz ausschütten
können und darüber reden befreit schon
mal
und die haben ihr herz ausgeschüttet man
kriegt mit ok man ist ja nicht alleine
auch andere haben ihr päckchen zu tragen
und es tröstet das war einfach gut hat
gut getan und durch die bewegung finde
ich ist es halt immer du schwitzt und du
schwitzt auch gewisse sachen raus ja
nicht nur müll im gewebe sondern auch
mal aus deinem kopf und man wird wieder
frei und ja es tut gut
obwohl es mich nach wie vor bewegt weil
ich mein papa total geliebt habe und
damit kommen wir zum fünften und letzten
typ nämlich dem biografischen neustart
das sind jetzt also wohlgemerkt menschen
deren leben nicht durch ein äußeres
ungeplantes ereignis erschüttert wurde
sondern die selber einbruch in ihrem
lebenslauf gesucht haben und die ein
neues leben beginnen wollen
ja also um ein beispiel zu nennen es
sind nicht die menschen die von ihrem
partner verlassen wurden so im fall wie
der biografischen krise sondern sind
eher menschen die ihren partner
verlassen haben und nun ein neues leben
beginnen wollen
und auch die suchen sehr intensiven
austausch mit anderen
pilgern die sind für sie immens wichtig
weil die anderen sie in ihrer identitäts
rekonstruktion bestärken sie sind ja
sehr alleine gelassen zunächst mit mit
dieser strategie ja das bisherige leben
über den haufen zu werfen und noch
einmal neu zu starten und nun finden sie
auf dem jakobsweg andere dies in
ähnlicher weise auch gemacht haben und
bestätigen sich gegenseitig können
gemeinsam identitäts arbeit leisten
in puncto körperlichkeit geht es den
pilgern dieses typs darum den eigenen
körper zu bezwingen
sozusagen ein beweis für den neustart ja
also die sagen sich wenn ich das hier
schaffe wenn ich diesen weg schaffe dann
schaffe ich es zu hause auch mein neues
leben zu leben und was das heimische
soziale umfeld angeht spielt das nun
wieder eine größere rolle
ja es geht nämlich darum auf dem
jakobsweg so etwas wie eine
heldengeschichte zu schreiben ja die
auch dazu dienen soll sich wenn man dann
nach hause wieder kommt also im
heimischen sozialen umfeld gegenüber als
neuer mensch zu präsentieren
auch hierzu noch ein letzter interview
auszug jetzt sprechen wir von einem
deutschen mann mitte 30
er erzählt uns von seinem arbeitsleben
und hat im übrigen auch eine
interessante geschichte
er ist nämlich nicht wie es die meisten
tun in den pyrenäen den jakobsweg
gestartet sondern er ist tatsächlich aus
süddeutschland also von zu hause aus los
gepilgert und war glaube ich zum
zeitpunkt als wir ihn interviewt haben
schon drei monate unterwegs
er sagt über sein berufsleben bin dann
in den betrieb zurück wo ich gelernt
habe für drei monate
dann habe ich den betrieb gewechselt und
da habe ich jetzt gearbeitet acht jahre
und habe aber die ganze zeit schon
gemerkt dass der beruf mir nichts gibt
also ich war unglücklich und habe aber
nie den mut gehabt irgendetwas neues
anzufangen bei absolut unglücklich in
dem beruf bin jeden tag wider willen auf
die arbeit gefahren
in der zeit hat
als ich gemerkt habe das macht mir
keinen spaß dann habe ich halt auch viel
getrunken und habe versucht die probleme
damit zu beseitigen was natürlich
schwachsinn ist aber dann gedacht so
kann es nicht weitergehen
du musst jetzt noch 30 oder 35 jahre
arbeiten habe gesagt es muss doch noch
was anderes geben als das kannst du
nicht weiterleben
ich wusste nicht was ich machen will was
ich arbeiten kann nach was ich suchen
soll
habe dann mit dem trinken aufgehört und
es ist halt schwer eine tür zuzumachen
baidu hatten monatlich dein geld du
gewöhnst dich daran und es ist schwer zu
sagen ich mache jetzt etwas anderes da
hatte ich angst vor
aber dann habe ich halt von heute auf
morgen gesagt ich könnte die
gemeinschaft weil ich einfach eine zeit
gebraucht habe für mich nachzudenken was
ich wer ich bin
so soll es weitergehen ich habe keine
ziele mehr gehabt ich bin quasi nach
meiner ausbildung stehen geblieben
aber mir keine neuen ziele mehr gesetzt
ja und so habe ich mir dann gedacht du
musst den job kündigen du musst die tür
zumachen um eine andere art auf zu
machen dass ich dann gesagt habe okay
den jakobsweg gehst du jetzt du wirst du
bestimmt viele leute treffen viele
gespräche haben
du wirst viel zeit haben über dich
selber nachzudenken
ja so bin ich jetzt auf dem weg das also
unser forschungsergebnis der pilger
studie
wir haben diese fünf typen aus den
empirischen daten entwickeln können
biografische bilanzierung wie grafische
krise biografischer auszahlen biografie
übergang und biografischer neustart
typen die wenn man es noch mal in dieser
übersicht anschaut auch durchaus
kontrast tief voneinander abzugrenzen
sind beispielsweise ist es so dass die
biografischen bilanziere die stille
suchen wenig kommunizieren auf dem
jakobsweg während die biografisch neu
starten ganz intensiven austausch haben
ja um ihre identität neu zu
rekonstruieren oder um ein anderes
beispiel zu nennen
ja die bürger des typs biografische
krise für die ist das heimische soziale
umfeld völlig unbedeutend während die
biografischen neustart als explizit mit
decken weil sie eine heldengeschichte
leiden und sich zu hause neu
präsentieren wollen und was man
vielleicht auch sieht deswegen habe ich
ihnen jetzt noch mal relativ ausführlich
auch unsere empirischen daten selbst
gezeigt dass diese typologie ja im sinne
eines theoretischen soziologischen
modell tatsächlich etwas ist was in
empirischen daten verankert und
begründet ist
weshalb man in der tat auch von einer
grounded theory sprechen kann
und damit sind wir nicht nur am ende des
forschungsprozesses unserer pilger
studie sondern auch am ende unserer
online vorlesung zur qualitativen
sozialforschung
ich hoffe ich konnte ihnen hier auch an
einem forschungspraxis beispiel ja also
zeigen was mit brauner theorie gemeint
ist wie man offen kodiert die man axial
codiert anhand eines codier paradigmas
und wie man dann in der forschungspraxis
später zum selektiven kodieren über geht
um ein theoretisches modell und oder
eine typologie zu entwickeln
gerne möchte ich sie noch mal einladen
wenn sie das modul 1 2 studieren sich
mal die übungsaufgabe im rudel
anzuschauen das transkript und mal zu
versuchen es mittels einer grounded
theory methodologie auszuwerten gerne
geben behindern wie gesagt dazu eine
rückmeldung und damit bedanke mich sehr
für die aufmerksamkeit wünsche ihnen
viel freude war ihr eigener empirischen
forschungen und verbleibe mit herzlichen
grüßen anfragen kinder